[Musique]
c'est ici à Achères le marché animé par
la soif de création Grégory a décidé de
consacrer sa vie au street art ce
créatif passionné retranscrit dans son
art des émotions fortes grâce à la Power
du noir et du blanc c'est lui qui le dit
et vous allez voir que grâce à la
couleur et les projections il a déjà
refait le portrait à plus d'un et
notamment Bart Simpson
[Musique]
je fais le lancement du début de mon
émission madame oui je sais
[Musique]
magnifique jardin mon Grégory
c'est un paradoxe
il y a un chien une dame qui court après
[Musique]
donc là on est dans l'atelier de Greg
premier truc qui m'interpelle tous ces
visages là on est vraiment sur des
visages africains ouais l'Afrique c'est
quelque chose qui est qui me parle
beaucoup de par mon expérience voilà
j'ai beaucoup côtoyé de communauté de
jeunes de communauté différentes et
voilà on est j'ai baigné là dedans et
donc c'est quelque chose qui ressort là
il y a une autre femme par contre on les
moins en Afrique déjà c'est c'est Jeanne
d'Arc donc ce support là il part je l'ai
vendu au Salon de l'Habitat il y a quoi
il y a 15 jours donc voilà j'ai récupéré
un vieux support dans la brocante de mon
village l'objectif c'est d'éviter que ça
tombe dans l'oubli que ça finisse à la
poubelle je pense que l'histoire en fait
ça permet d'éviter les erreurs qu'on a
déjà faites et donc je trouve que c'est
important de de remettre au goût du jour
tout ce qu'on nous a appris et de
transmettre c'est hyper important pour
moi surtout dans l'art alors justement
transmettre les on va parler un peu de
la jeunesse parce que tu transmets
justement ton savoir faire le spray
painting aux jeunes d'Achères le marché
oui je suis éducateur au sein de mon
village et en fait dès que j'ai monté
mon mon activité profiter de street
artiste une de mes priorités c'était de
monter des cours auprès des jeunes pour
en fait leur transmettre ce que moi ça
m'a apporté et je trouve que c'est hyper
important d'avoir un côté lâcher prise
dans l'art ou justement il y a pas de il
y a pas de barrière pour les jeunes tu
seras mon professeur à moi là je vais te
faire comme avec mes élèves et ben tu
vas tu vas pratiquer on pratique en
pratique tu sais t'en servir bien sûr
sur
un petit va et juste des petits coups
comme ça tout ça
tu peux même te rapprocher vas-y vas-y
voilà que les petits coups est-ce que
c'est tard ça s'apprend on tour on t'a
appris tu as pris des cours je suis
autodidacte de tout que ça soit le
dessin la bombe bah en fait je suis très
practicien si tu veux j'aime bien passer
à l'action et puis bah je vais apprendre
mes erreurs donc je continue je continue
je continue je continue déjà Greg merci
de m'avoir permis de participer à cette
œuvre et je suis vraiment curieux de
voir ce qui est en dessous
moi aussi donc elle est toujours comme
ça j'ai toujours là c'est fou toi d'un
seul coup on va mettre la finition
non énorme c'est génial franchement la
bogosité de ce type je sais pas qui qui
c'est mais beau gosse quoi je trouve
qu'il a des yeux franchement
magnifique franchement magnifique super
du coup je vais te prendre en photo avec
toi-même ok d'accord ouais bah vas-y
merci Sabrina
en tout cas on se retrouve vraiment très
fort pour refaire le portrait ça
redoutable redoutable